hello everyone and welcome to some  urgent news from the chess world as  usual i'm only using this format when  there is something that absolutely must  be shared and uh that something is that  magnus carlsen has withdrawn from the  saint louis chess tournament we don't  know why  the only thing we know that he tweeted i  withdrawn from the tournament i've  always enjoyed playing in the st louis  chess club and hope to be back in the  future and with this tweet he also  included a video of mourinho saying that  if i speak i'm in big trouble now what  actually happened here why did magnus uh  withdraw from the tournament uh he  didn't notify anyone he just didn't show  up or the the granchester official  account just confirmed that  and um yeah this is the first time ever  in history that magnus carlsen has  withdrawn from the tournament no one  knows why now mamadyarov does not have  an opponent for today uh if i know more  i will inform you that's it for now see  you soon